foreign
[Music]
[Music]
will not be imprisoned again
[Music]
I hear you've been busy making yourself
the Empire's Most Wanted
[Music]
a Jedi
remind our friend here why is God under
supposed to be dead
[Music]
the Empire's only grown stronger
[Music]
okay
[Music]
thanks bud
part of the joke guesses
the Jedi is a threat
now that we have this
[Music]
as long as we fight
[Music]
thank you
hope survives
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
the hero of Star Wars Jedi Survivor
Cameron Monahan
it's an incredible honor to wield this
lightsaber again
and I think I can speak for everybody at
respawn EA and lucasfilm when I say how
incredibly excited we are to show our
work on Jedi Survivor
I had the chance to play the game
recently and I can honestly say that
this is one of the best Star Wars games
of all time and that's saying something
I have no doubt
that you might when you play it too
and I just gotta say that I am so
incredibly lucky to be a part of this
incredible project and it's really
something extraordinary so
we'll see you all in a galaxy far far
away March 17th and until then
May the force be with you
[Applause]